concentration maximale à chaque frappe
visualisation de la table et calcul de
trajectoire en tout genre le billard est
une sciance exacte pourtant le but du
jeu est à priori très simple rentrer les
boules jaunes ou rouges et terminer par
la noire pour gagner la partie dans ce
domaine Jonathan driglas excelle en
finale de la 8e manche de Coupe de
France de Black ball ce weekend il est
opposé au numéro 1 français Christophe
Lambert le derquis mène rapidement 2-0
avant la belle réaction du multiple
champion de France qui repasse devant
3-2 maisathend glass conclut la finale
en boulet canon et impose une sèche dans
la dernière manche pour s'imposer 54 ça
s'est bien passé on va dire à ma casse
au début lui ça s'est pas trop bien
passé au début après les jeux sont un
peu inversés donc ça fait que ça a été
un peu serré et j'ai réussi à faire
l'écart avec une petite ferme à la belle
com on va la belle à deux donc je il
casse il rentre pas malheureusement je
ferme la table ça fait que il y a pas eu
trop de chance non plus et un peu plus
de réussite pour moi que pour lui il
remporte là son deuxème open de Black
ball et se qualifie pour le championnat
de France fin juin pourtant il ne
participe qu'à sa première saison
fédérale et vise déjà une qualification
au futur championnat du
monde